[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein nachgemacht video wie
in der letzten zeit so oft und zwar was
ganz spontan ist denn der murat hat
kinder milch schnitte joghurt in wall
street style joghurt entdeckt mit mango
maracuja und das ist im prinzip wie so
eine art milch schnitte aber ein heller
form und wir werden jetzt die verkostung
machen und wer könnte das besser machen
als meine milch schnitte murat ich mich
beim bachelor und mische ich mich
richtig cool ich hatte ja schon mal
milch schnitte nachgemacht video mit
stellen nach der macht wieder gemacht
damals ja hat auch über ist
eingeschlagen
der sturm hat noch etwas macht gemacht
und jeder sturm buffett gibt mir ein
stummer vorschläge hat auch was chris
nacht gemacht und jetzt gibt es neue
sorgen dass auch als anlass genommen
diese dieses video hier etwas
vereinfacht und mit ganz klaren
anweisungen zu machen
also ich muss sagen griechen trotz mega
ja ja ich will mir schmeckt auch gut
wobei es ganz anders aussieht schon früh
probierte ich es echt nicht probiert
aber es sieht ganz anders aus weil das
ist erhält und das riecht auch und aber
ich finde maracuja recht besser deswegen
würde ich jetzt vor einem von der
hochheimer akoya nach machen weil er so
gut finden würde und so kannst du das
nicht als trauzimmer
ja ich mache ist der xxl manager der
aber ganz groß und was ich rufe ich
würde das ist komisch aus als wäre da
irgendwas darauf könnte es dunkel machen
das ist nicht okay so es ist eigentlich
recht trocken geschmacklos war es
bedingt komische exhibition erinnerung
ja wenn man es zusammen ist ist sein
und jetzt die creme krass kennt ihr das
ist ein hit war doch nicht so ernährung
solero nicht eins zu eins wie solero
bruder mir noch älter seid split damals
gab es noch keine handys damals unter 30
bin kenne ich nicht so dass da hier nur
so gespickt ist
da habe ich nicht so findet muss ich
sagen ich mache gerne von dem teig recht
trocken gemacht so wie es schmeckt eins
zu eins wie früher ja wie der flug über
ihr wisst wänden mora sagt wenn joghurt
ist es ein kompliment ok meine dieser
aussage hat sich bereit machen den koch
zeigt bezahlt eine verfolgung ist jetzt
sehen auch weber schmeckt wirklich wie
splitt und zu ok ich probiere jetzt mein
glück wir machen die version ganz groß
mango maracuja xx du kannst du auch hoch
machen also ich finde das schade das ist
nicht wirklich soll es nicht so man nur
was jetzt auch regional
ok also ich mache jetzt aber wenig
größer machen müsste ich noch höher
machen
ok ich überlegte mir auch ich fange
jetzt mal mit der vorbereitung der
füllung an
in der creme ist konzentrierter joghurt
ich nehme jetzt hier meinen
zehnprozentigen sahne joghurt und
konzentriert bedeutet dass er einfach
noch weniger flüssigkeit hat ihr könnt
es auch schon am vortag machen nehmt
einfach eine große schüssel ein hase und
dann entweder so ein multi oder eben ein
sauberes geschirr tuch und jetzt gebe
ich hier den joghurt rein und hängen ihn
sozusagen ein bisschen ab so dass
einfach die flüssigkeit die hier noch
drin ist so ein bisschen abtropfen kann
aber da ist ja schon richtig schön
stichfest müsste eigentlich nicht machen
aber ich mach sitzt trotzdem dass er
einfach noch ein bisschen mit weniger
flüssigkeit hat und während der dann im
kühlschrank sozusagen abhängt kann ich
schon mal den teil
machen ich gucke jetzt einfach mal ob
das klappt bei joghurt abgehängt habe
ich selber jetzt auch noch nicht und wie
gesagt ist er ja schon schön stichfest
aber ich probleme
für den teig verwende ich vier eier 100
gramm zucker etwas salz 30 gramm honig
wandel extrakt 140 gramm mehl und einen
halben teelöffel backpulver zehn gramm
kakao und 50 gramm mineralwasser die
original milchschnitte ist 9 x 4 cm groß
ich habe mit ihr ausgerechnet also
einfach bereits wir machen sie nämlich
36 x 16 cm groß also ganz einfach einen
gleich backen und dann wird es eben
halbiert der teig bei der original
milchschnitte hat 3 mm jeweils und ich
mache jetzt einfach dicker und die creme
eben auch dicker also wir machen das
ganze schon proportional größer im xxl
format
okay die zutaten sind zimmer war jetzt
könnt ihr zuerst mal die eier in die
rührschüssel geben
zucker und salz dazu da ich noch nie in
der milch schritten produktion gesehen
habe weiß ich nicht ob da honig im teig
steckt oder in der creme
ich glaube ich mache einfach beides also
ich ja noch ein bisschen honig und
bissle vanille extrakt für den sally
touch und jetzt wird die masse einfach
schön schaumig verrührt und ich kann in
der zwischenzeit schon mehl backpulver
und kakao mission
[Musik]
jetzt ist die masse schön schaumig das
können wir natürlich auch mit einem
handrührgerät machen
jetzt kann ich hier das mehl und
trockenen zutaten dazu 7
[Musik]
hier noch das wasser dazu und jetzt
einfach ganz kurz verrühren
jetzt habe ich hier meinen back rahmen
auf die größte einstellung eingestellt
und kann jetzt den teig hier eingeben
sieht so ein bisschen flüssiger
biskuitteig deswegen habe ich jetzt hier
auch wasser rennen damit sich schön
verteilt und auch backpulver ich denke
von der farbe her kommt das ganz gut hin
den verstreiche ich jetzt schön glatt
und dann kommt da einfach bei 200 grad
in den backofen wird kurz gebacken
es geht auch wirklich super schnell und
kommt bei bizkit platten immer darauf
achten eher hausbacken und kurz damit er
eben nicht trocken wird
[Musik]
jetzt ab in den backofen
ich mag neun minuten
der kuchen ist jetzt fertig gebacken die
wir ist glatt löse ich jetzt hier kurz
ab und stürzt sie dann auch sofort so
kann so schön abkühlen und dann kann man
das hier nämlich schön herauslösen
ich lege jetzt hier einfach eine zweite
bank folie drauf und eine torte retter
und nehme ich nur dann ist es noch heiß
und einstürzen
und jetzt hoffe ich dass ich die
oberfläche wie bei der original milch
schnitte habe ein bisschen dunkler aber
ist nicht schlimm
kurz ablösen und so lasse ich jetzt
einfach komplett abkühlen die beste
platte ist jetzt abgekühlt jetzt geht es
direkt an die füllung zum einen mache
ich ja die joghurt füllung habt ihr denn
joghurt bereits abgehangen und dann gibt
es eben noch diese maracuja mango
füllung ich zeige euch mal kurz die
restlichen zutaten für die creme brauche
ich wie gesagt einen kilo sahnejoghurt
50 gramm honig 40 gramm puderzucker 500
gramm sahne und salat zum fest werden
dann brauche ich noch die frucht füllung
dafür nämlich eine reife mango ich
brauche maracuja es 100 gramm wasser 30
kampfstärke und etwa 60 gramm zucker
ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal leben man
gut denn jetzt wird erstmal die frucht
schulung vorbereitet
das werde ich hier am stein entlang weg
stein kern entfernen wahrscheinlich wohl
eher oder ist diese brown aber ist nicht
schlimm das schneiden weg und wagen
jetzt braucht ihr nämlich das
fruchtfleisch dann etwa um stücken und
hier wegschneiden
[Musik]
er ist die schnitt bei mir wird sagt
willig 300 wie viel habe ich 300 und das
ist zum naschen
das habe ich hier noch die maracuja das
wasser werde ich jetzt hier mit der
mango pürieren
daher brauche ich wasser ihr könnt auch
saft nehmen dann könnt ihr euch sogar
den zucker vielleicht komplett sparen es
kommt darauf an wie süß die maracuja ist
und eben auch die mango und die hier
immer so ein bisschen so widerspenstig
die halbierte weg sie auch ab dann
streiche ich sie aber durch ein sieb
denn ich möchte er die kerne nicht mit
drin haben und den saft dann fange ich
jetzt auch auf
[Musik]
das mango curry kommt jetzt hier direkt
in einen topf das habe ich ja schon
abgewogen und das wasser ist jetzt auch
dabei da kommt jetzt auch das maracuja
fruchtfleisch bzw der saft hat so oder
ob die zwei kerne versteckt sind jetzt
auch 100 gramm und die kerne habe ich
übrigens aufgehoben die bitte nicht
wegschmeißen maracuja sind ja auch jetzt
nicht ganz günstig die könnte jetzt
entweder für einen smoothie
weiterverwenden oder in joghurt
einrühren und einfach ebenso es also die
benutze ich auf jeden fall noch weiter
dann noch etwas zucker ich nehme jetzt
anteile und die stärke und dann finde
ich das jetzt hier kurz genug um frei
und kochs dann auf und wenn doch die
empirie entstehen müsste das hat einfach
noch mal kurz kurieren
[Musik]
merkst du coeur koma nein maracuja
hier ist jetzt die maracuja masse die
darf jetzt hier abkühlen und ich kann
ihnen der zwischenzeit die creme zu
bereiten
jetzt schaue ich noch was mein joghurt
macht schon einiges am tätigkeit aber
ich denke wenn ich ihnen jetzt noch
etwas drücken kommt noch etwas
flüssigkeit raus ok ich möchte nämlich
gucken wie viel gramm ich habe und ich
denke mir so hoch wo ist der joghurt ist
wow genial
guck mal so ist die konsistenz also
richtig schön fest und dafür solltet ihr
wirklich den zehnprozentigen joghurt
nehmen denn ansonsten wenn ihr nur 1,5
oder 35 nimmt bleibt ja nichts mehr
übrig sodass schön cremig jetzt probiert
den x men geschmeckt hat er schon gut
und jetzt ist er noch mal einfach
trocken voll perfekt denn ich glaube
wenn ich das jetzt nicht gemacht hätte
dann bestünde die gefahr dass später die
torte ein bisschen lässt jetzt werde ich
das ganz kurz ab sagt wie viel gramm
nicht übrig habe es sind 630 wahnsinn
und den rest nicht wegschmeißen das
könnte jetzt einfach trinken ja dass das
molke das sage ich jetzt einfach so wenn
es einer besser weiß bitte unten in die
kommentare schreiben
und jetzt kann ich hier den joghurt mit
dem honig will den puderzucker habe ich
bereits mit der sahne steif geschlagen
[Applaus]
jetzt die sahne unterheben
nach seiner tat habe ich hier auch drin
mal gucken ob ich noch ein bisschen
salat benötige aber eigentlich ist der
joghurt jetzt fest genug aber ich glaube
zur sicherheit ist schön standfest ist
nämlich noch ein bisschen salat
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt die platte das soll
die außenseite sein also stürzte ich sie
jetzt die oberste schicht weg aber das
ist ganz gut so
die wollen wir sowieso nicht haben und
jetzt halbiere ich die platte
[Musik]
perfekt das sind jetzt die
milchschnitten platten jetzt völlig den
themen spritzbeutel mit einer großen
machtfülle vorne
es geht auch ohne aber mit geht es ein
bisschen einfacher jetzt für mich
und jetzt kommt hier die creme rein und
kleinen run klassisch wie bei der
original milch schnitte
[Musik]
jetzt bisschen glatt streichen
jetzt kommt hier eine umrandung rein
[Musik]
okay das kann ich die creme schon mal
kühl stellen diese füllung ist jetzt nur
noch lauwarm und wird jetzt hier rein
gegossen
das gucke ich mir wahrscheinlich habe
ich ein bisschen zu viel gemacht
[Musik]
es kommt jetzt kurz in den kühlschrank
bis die masse schön kalt ist und dann
völlig das ganze mit der creme auf und
sind sozusagen fertig
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier die restliche creme
drauf
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt hier noch der deckel
drauf
[Musik]
fertig ist die krise möglich schnitte
kurz in den kühlschrank
und dann darf morath probieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und zwar möchte ich jetzt den anschnitt
so machen wie auf dem bild das ist immer
so ein perfekter bis erklärt da das xxl
ist nehmen wir jetzt keinen gebiss
sondern ich schnell zu haben aber das
ist den leuten zeigen kann
ich muss einfach krieg so eine ecke ja
weil ich viele zonen runden anstellt
damit das foto gleich kohle du bist eine
schlaue frau ich weiß ich bin ein
schlauer mann war so sieht's aus diese
riesen wick david ich darf doch zuerst
also also jetzt mal vom aussehen her
kann man nichts sagen aber das sagen du
hast die farben fast getroffen
hier liegt ja entschuldigung aber bei
mir ist die farbe viel appetitlicher der
musik hat sagen also liebe wer hat s
gemacht verrät kinder hin dass kinder
paroli weg kinder
herr brok family produzenten meine
fortschritte gemacht wirklich schöner zu
nennen das ist schön auch das leckere
essen ist immer noch ein jahr und ist
die poren sind auch roh ist endlich
appetitlicher aus ich finde es auch
schon jetzt probiert ihn manchmal selbst
auch war geschmacklich gut aber es war
halt schon mittel trocken hat er das ist
gerade gemacht einfach so was hab ich
mal probieren
ich kann es ja auch aus dem rathaus
stellen
aber ich mache das nicht wirklich sagt
können sie mir bitte nicht so gutem
essen
das schmeckt den joghurt es ist ja auch
joghurt in bronze lecker und zum ersten
mal schmecke ich denn die honig in der
milch schnitte
den habe ich noch nie geschmeckt aber
hier in hier drin schmecke ich ihn und
der joghurt butter joghurt ist richtig
lecker darin folgen
eigentlich wollte samira unsere
fotografen chris stück darauf hier zum
fotografieren
ich habe mir das immer gewünscht als
kind mit ihr zu haben ohne ende
santhera hat das stück existiert leider
nicht mehr
hmm naja wer fotografiert im schnitt
wichtig natürlich ganz ganz wichtiges
wollen ist die kühlung ich kann es mir
wichtig ist das heißt bevor das
anschneiden immer zwei schuldige
kühlschrank bei machen das ist richtig
es wird voll gut so zart und weich
ich meine dass wahrscheinlich die
doppelte portion wieso 1 aber er ist
halt nur noch er sagt gar nichts mehr
jedenfalls egal um den heißen brei
herumgeredet probiert das rezept gerne
aus alle infos findet ihr noch mal in
meiner apps kostenlos können euch gerne
herunterladen und schreibt gerne in die
kommentare was ich als nächstes nach
machen soll
ich muss wirklich sagen dass mich bei
der version die mango maracuja wirklich
angelacht hat waldfrucht kann ich jetzt
letzte lecker dafür fand der josch
waldfrucht leckeren von waldburg auch
cool war auch gut aber schreibt einfach
in die kommentare was ich als nächstes
machen soll und ob ich sie in
kleinformat oder xxl machen soll
ich finde zwar mit klubboss cool doch
was richtig cool und zwar in allen
diesen schokoriegel club ist kannst du
immer nachmachen xxl oder normal wie zum
beispiel damals die tricks und die
mounties und so auch in normal nachricht
aber nicht die waffe kloppers wo das
weiß ich jetzt mein schwung regelung
muss der ist sowas ist endgegner bin ich
aber richtig kümmern jetzt auch fotos
unseren darf moratti mit genau schmeckt
auch holen
wenn ich auf einmal hohler schmeckt
besser genau macht es ist festzustellen
dass ich hier bestimmt und lag nur die
creme raus na ja ist doch die menschen
sowie durch die andere gegessen strecke
runter ja
[Musik]